I think a lot of people are like you and
I just kind of coming around on the idea
that so much of frankly what goes on in
this country today is total [ __ ] hey
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me on the
Rubin report this week is the host of
I'll kick the coverage on Fox Sports
Radio and the author of Republicans wear
sneakers to end one of the breasts
guests they Travis welcome back to the
Rubin report
I appreciate it's been we were just
talking before we started here I came in
October of 2017 so it's been almost two
years since we hung out last time and I
got great feedback when I was hanging
out with you last time I appreciate
you're gonna come on my new podcast as
well during the same kind of timeframe
and the world may have just gone crazier
you know you're hoping that maybe the
world would go less crazy
we talked back in October of seventeen
and it seems like things that just
continued to spin wildly that does fit
well with my notes because yes world has
gotten crazier citizen yeah it's been
about a year and a half yeah that I've
been waiting to say that stupid breast
joke yeah sound on Twitter about a
thousand yes but the thing that kind of
put you on the map outside of the sports
world yeah let's just recap that that
little nonsense because it does kind of
capture yeah everything related to the
media and outrage and all that you dared
to say that you like breasts and see and
and the First Amendment and I'm still
banned by seeing it like that do you
think about all the people that they've
had on who've done all the crazy things
that they like I mean all of the Michael
avenatti who's been on you know and that
was you know he's on hundreds of times
and now he's you know under under siege
with all the different charges against
him but yeah they banned me for that for
saying I the only two things in the
world that you know I can believed in
completely the First Amendment and boobs
and look it was good for me the book
Republicans by sneakers too came out and
it did really well bestseller and got a
lot of attention back in September I
think the paperbacks coming out I know
you're working on your own book right
now but I think it gall that government
galvanized for many people what I think
typically happens which is the absurdity
of false outrage and what is and what
cannot be said and what
shouldn't be said I think a lot of
people are like you and I just kind of
coming around on the idea that so much
of frankly what goes on in this country
today is total [ __ ] it's just
endless yes yes and I'm glad you said
something there about the what's
happened to you since then yeah because
I think a lot of people that care about
what you do that watch this show that
are paying attention to the culture war
and all that they still fear that the
mob will destroy yes and what I've been
trying to show people just through my
own life every week that the New York
Times calls me alright or just the next
right right right right right I'm like
you know if you actually take a breath
and don't lose your [ __ ] in the middle
of it yes not only will you survive you
will most likely thrive it after and I
think you're an example of that I think
so and and I think you're right there is
this rush to apologize anytime someone
criticizes you even if you're sticking
to things that you have long said in
your career my radio show is thriving
you know nationwide we went over 300
affiliates and one of the wild things I
think that would surprise people is my
show is dominating in a lot of different
markets right like our ratings in Los
Angeles are up something like 400
percent in the past couple of years
right our numbers in Kansas City are up
insanely on the East Coast we have done
insanely well in the South where I'm
from in Nashville we continue to do
outstanding the podcast numbers are
booming that I started a television show
daily on fs1 called
lock it in which is a focused on sports
gambling but we have a lot of fun on
there and and I've continued to be as
outspoken as I ever have and what I have
seen I don't know about you but is
people get frustrated because they want
to take you down and when you stick to
what you believe in the benefit is a lot
of people have your back yeah
and they may not have your back in the
same way publicly that you can but I am
a big and have long been in law school I
I kind of have come to this as I've
gotten older a big believer in the
marketplace of ideas and if we're
artificially constraining what people
feel comfortable talking about I think
it leads to a lot of the inks that exist
in our country today and so particularly
in the world of sports there are so many
guys and girl
out there who regularly slide into my
DMS and say I a hundred percent agree
with everything that you say but because
of how I'm employed or who employs me I
don't feel comfortable getting out on
the battlefield like you do but keep
doing exactly what you're doing does
that type a person though drive you
crazy er than the person that doesn't
contact you that just remains quiet
because it's like you know you're not
Jesus you're doing your thing right like
I'm just a guy doing my thing and then
when I get these messages from often
people that are more popular than yeah
yeah yeah yeah then I am have more money
than I am and they're subtly like yeah
keep doing it it's like well I'm doing
what I think is right but like you know
you get in this to like get some skin in
the game it's an interesting question I
I think what protected me early on was I
started my own site outkick and I'll
kick the coverage initially just writing
now we do a lot of videos now obviously
it's a lot of audio as well in fact we
do more video and audio than we do
writing almost now and once I started to
produce a revenue and realize and I
think you probably have gotten there too
you can take a breath and be like okay
I'm never gonna go hungry right I think
anybody who tries to get into media and
especially early on when I left the
practice of law my first question was oh
my god is my family gonna start to death
right am I gonna have to abandon my
media career to go back to practicing
law it's and it's hard to get over that
that fear is always in the back of your
mind because we live in this cancel'
culture that somebody wants to believe
they're going to cancel you so it's I
guess I wish that there were more people
who wanted to speak out but if you're
employed solely by a major corporation
today I totally understand the fear of I
got kids you know I got a mortgage
payment I got my kids college funds that
I'm worried about in everything else and
frankly the way I think about it too is
that leaves me a huge area to to own
right where there are a lot of people
who may agree with me which proves you
know the audience response to it but
others are afraid to say what I'm saying
even if they agree with it which to me
you know from a pure business
perspective I'm like well I'll just keep
rolling right I mean what do you think
it is about some people that are willing
to kind of walk into that thing yeah
because people will say that to me all
the time though
they always say that I'm brave yeah I'm
always like it's not something I think
about him just doing what I think is
right that's it that's a great line
because when I was a kid growing up my
favorite quote was from Davy Crockett in
Davy Crockett's most famous quote I
think still is although who knows be
sure you're read some news yeah yeah
yeah be sure you're right and then go
ahead and so by the time I come out with
an opinion I have worked through every
permutation of that opinion you know
like if I give an opinion and somebody
immediately responds on Twitter well did
you think about X which always happens
yeah and in fact we do on the radio show
sometimes we'll do a segment where I
will flip and start arguing the other
side and I think that's the lawyer
training in me but by the time I go out
with an opinion I'm not just shooting
off at the lip like I have kind of in my
head worked through every different
angle of an argument and once I'm
convinced that my opinion is right I'm
comfortable putting it out there now
here's the other thing if you think I'm
wrong it doesn't bother me Yeah right
like I almost think I remember when when
there was the argument over push of Igor
and the two sides of that argument I
think David Boies had Al Gore and the
other side I'm forgetting the guy that
Ted Olson I believe was the other side
and they argued as hard as they could in
front of the Supreme Court and then I
think they shook hands afterwards I may
have gone out for a beer because they
knew that it wasn't then in their hands
the Supreme Court had the decision to
make each of them had made the argument
for their side as good as they possibly
can and that's kind of the era that I
wish we could go back to where we can
disagree in the old-school Senate but
you could have a situation where Orrin
Hatch and and Ted Kennedy are really
good friends and that's kind of what
drove me crazy about this whole Joe
Biden flare-up right the segregationist
comment like just because you work with
someone doesn't mean you agree with
everything that they've ever said and
this idea that you have to be a constant
war with someone is just something that
I repudiate and reject is it even worse
than that in that it's really a war with
the past yeah when they get up there and
they say well Biden you talk to these
people because he's actually got a for a
record yeah doesn't mean he loved
everybody and we don't even have to get
into the minutiae of what yeah
or the people right hands he shook or
any of that but it's actually an erasure
of the past yes you don't just magically
you know go like that and hope okay
everything's great we're in 2019 we're
all evolved and perfect which is so
ridiculous yeah I always I always like
to say because I you know I'm a big
history guy right and you know the
Confederate statue debate and everything
else we live in an era where we believe
that we are everything that's perfect in
the world and I was having this
conversation that yeah yeah yeah right
they're all idiots how do they ever make
mistakes but the reality is that 200
years from now we are going to be
advocating and embracing even the most
alok members of our society for things
that others will find later to be
abhorrent
that's just how history works right and
so I you know the idea that we've
reached the end of history is it's kind
of fascinating to me because I think 200
years from now it might well be and I'm
just tossing one out then anybody who
eats meat is an infidel right like the
idea that you could have ever eaten yeah
that will be crazy might well happen
right and and so our people 200 years
from now gonna be like oh we got to tear
down this mornin luther king statue
because he ate meat we got to tear down
this statue of John F Kennedy because
can you believe he liked the steak you
know wasn't for gaming the first time
you ran for president in fact you gonna
tear that library down I know that it
right now in 2008 Obama's entire
platform would be the most moderate
platform of any Democrat running for
president right now and people would say
is this guy electable
so what does that tell you about
internet culture cuz yeah it is exactly
where we started here which is you were
on the show a year and a half ago we
were talking about this you were right
in the midst of your own little mob yeah
and it's like we've thrived since then
and many other people have the
institutions have continued to crumble I
mean we've watched the way the trust in
mainstream media humbled watch the way
trust in in sports media has Yambol
while the little guy now doing their own
thing is doing great what what does that
tell you about just the the speed that
we're getting the information at and and
where people are going to trust things
we're we're in a disruptive cycle I
don't think there's any doubt at all and
what I say all the time is the only
thing I can do and I love what you do
about this as well is try to be as
honest as possible with my audience
right and so the things that I
thing get attacked for by people who
don't like me and I'm sure you see this
all the time to your like I address that
all the time right and so I think trying
to be as authentic as possible is
ultimately the connection and I think
large institutions do not seem authentic
because they got their fingers up in the
air and they're paying attention to the
vagaries of day-to-day responses on
social media I also think listening to
social media is insane
right I mean it's a tiny segment of the
population that's often very very active
and so we live in an age of abundant
criticism but I don't think we live in
an age of abundant reflection and I
think reflection is more important
oftentimes and criticism is the problem
though that social media is becoming our
only way of reflecting so yeah cuz the
institutions are crumbling and we don't
have these the nightly news show or
whatever that we can all basically trust
that social media has become the mirror
but now we're all cordoning off into our
own mirrors it's like it would be a good
example like Nancy Pelosi said this
thing recently about AOC and a lotto
Mart's like yeah she's like yeah they're
big on Twitter but they only have four
votes but then they all go after her on
Twitter and destroy her and then the
media loves that yeah the whole thing is
so out of whack with reality yeah or
it's the new reality which is just out
of whack works I think in general there
are a lot of people who aren't very
confident and this is what I always talk
about from a perspective of you know
let's say my world of sports media if
you are an executive and you have gotten
to the point where you are high up in
making decisions at a sports network
let's say I think the idea that you
would make a choice on who you think is
good
based on your 30 40 50 years of
expertise rising up to that level and
then because when it goes out publicly a
bunch of people on Twitter say I don't
like that guy or whatever that you would
allow that to be a reflection of the
real world mean there's a great stat
that's out right now that I saw where
it's something like 20 percent of people
are on Twitter let's use as an example
and of that 20 percent 80 percent of all
tweets are sent by like 10 percent of
the overall population right and we know
that Twitter leans far left we know that
you've been in your own battles over
this the social media company
as if those competent lead far-left
enough already
they're also magnifying those voices
right that reflect the culture by which
they wish were more popular and so
you're allowing ultimately you know
something like 2 or 3 percent of the
population that isn't it all reflective
of the universe to dictate decisions
that you make and I'll give you an
example and this is in the book I
remember talking with the ESPN execs and
they said Twitter hates Lou Holtz and
Chris Berman right old school guys at
MBA at ESPN Lou Holtz former Notre Dame
football coach college football guy
Chris Berman maybe the most iconic voice
in ESPN history right put ESPN on the
map and they said if you read the
mentions reflecting what they say on
social media everybody hates them but if
we are out in public
those guys get swarmed with positivity
such that we have to have security to
protect them and the question was do we
listen to social media or do we listen
to the real world and to me you got to
listen to the real world right because
social media is is not reflective of
real life it's funny because after this
past year where I was on a tour with
Peter said oh yeah 100 plus stops around
15 countries and I'd be looking at
mentions all day and you know actually
95% of them are positive yeah but you
know it's always that 5% and you know if
5% is several hundred it can feel like a
lot of things but then I'd meet people
on the street and meet people all over
the world at airports and you know
restaurants and everyone's great yeah
everyone's actually I was at IKEA this
weekend and a guy kind of gave me side
eye like yeah clearly didn't like me but
I was like that's as bad as it gets
right but if you're on social media all
day you feel like holy [ __ ] the world's
coming to what I say is I've never had a
person say a bad word to me face-to-face
yeah I mean it's wild and in fact the
opposite of that people will come up and
you know ask for a picture you know
people say if I ever see you I'm gonna
punch you right like that's really
comments on social media oh they got a
place yeah yeah yeah exactly and then
what happens is they show up and they
want a picture or it's even happen a
couple times like I'll block people
right on social media if they're sending
me obsessive you know 20 in a row tweets
or something because I do try to go
through and check every now and then I
don't spend as much time in it as I used
to but when I do that I've had people
come up to me be like man you blocked me
here's my Twitter handle I'm a big fan
I'm sorry I was drunk that night and I
just got carried away can you please I
mean and that's always I think
interesting because you know people are
just not accurate representations of
themselves on social media and and as
someone who tries to be as authentic and
honest as I possibly can on a day to day
basis because I think you know one of my
buddy said somehow by being the most
reasonable person in sports you've made
a career and I think that just kind of
speaks to the polarity of the universe
that we live in now that just being a
guy who's fairly middle-of-the-road
seems radical I know the feeling yeah I
know and I have many of similar beliefs
yeah and and kind of funny though that
so so the two of us that come from
wildly different place yeah we're in
different spheres that these worlds have
kind of collide yes that that as we
talked about last time that Sports has
become ridiculously political yes which
in many ways is why the institutions are
crumbling and the fact that a guy like
you who mostly cares about sports you
end up talking about a whole bunch of
stuff that really is just a sidebar but
that is where the energy is and in
saying something like hey the u.s. women
are great but I kind of wish Megan
Rapinoe had shut up and just go on to
the White House right or or you know the
u.s. women deserve whatever money they
can get in a market-based economy but
the men produce a lot more revenue and
people are like oh my god how dare you
say that and I'm like this is the most
rational you know reasonable perspective
or you know the NBA shouldn't ban the
word owners because it's not racially
insensitive like the owners of the team
yeah oh and I theoretically I although
this might be owned by Fox but they
dress me when I'm out here for
television but it's crazy like you know
like we're only going to define words by
thing and they replaced it with
governors which doesn't even mean the
same thing and by the way if you're
worried about negative racial
connotations there been a lot more
racist governors you know in the last 30
or 40 years right then there have been
racist team owners so all right let's do
that yes first I want to get back to
some of the gender stuff related to
chapter and all that but on the owner
front yeah the people that push these
ideas so I remember it was a couple
weeks ago we start here in this there
yeah yeah they're not going to call the
owners owners anymore and you see it you
see it starts spreading across social
media and people start saying this is a
good thing and you know there's a
connotation to slavery and right those
things and yet every part of you as a
functioning person knows this is
nonsense they own a team that yes it's a
business I own the production company
that produces this show do not I am the
people who are higher if they decide
that they don't want to work for you
anymore they can leave and go work
somewhere else I'm renting this Yeah
right like like you know it rightly you
know it yes it's obvious but what I
think social justice has done is its
created a situation where even basic
words now yes have become triggers for
some other thing and it's like do these
guys actually think they've done
anything good that's that's what I'm
always trying to figure yes I believe
this okay we're calling them governors
now do they walk home when they go honey
you know you're not gonna believe this I
did something I think it's all motivated
by fear so let's take a step back Adam
Silver is a white white guy who runs the
NBA right ultimately he's afraid if he
doesn't listen to a few Looney tune
black players and make this decision
that ultimately they could decide oh
wait Adam Silver's a white guy who runs
the NBA
he's like a plantation master right like
that's the analogy that they could
continue to build out why is he making
tens of millions of dollars a year when
he's primarily making money off the
labor of black men in the NBA right and
so I think what happens is anybody who's
watching that worldwide league must be
super easy but I think what happens is
it's an element of self-preservation so
I don't think Adam silver I think if you
gave him truth serum and he was sitting
here with you right now he'd say that's
an utterly ludicrous idea but I think
the problem is people in positions of
power are so afraid that they're gonna
end up the target that they go as far
left as they possibly can because that
way they can be like my hand what are
you talking about I'm super low like we
replaced the word owners with governors
I'm sensitive to your feelings and
that's a big problem is there's a
difference between hearing somebody's
argument and at least contemplating it
and being sensitive to an argument right
there are lots of dumb argument calling
an argument dumb is not insensitive
actually honors the argument to be
discussing it but I think that that
there like I did a poll I think that 95%
of sports fans do not think remotely
that the word owner is racist but people
like Adam silver in positions of power
are afraid that the platform that guy
like draymond Green has who wants to say
by the way draymond Green
said he was an owner in his Twitter bio
right remember like it's like these guys
are not even able to avoid hypocritical
behavior for a short segment of time
right like draymond Green says the word
owner is offensive and yet in his own
bio he's an owner and what ownership is
an a spiral gold in the United States in
capitalism right you want to own your
home you want to own a business you want
to own your educate like owning
something is a powerful thing for an
individual so and then you replace it
like you said with a word that doesn't
even mean the same thing and arguably so
first of all they are now governors of
teams right that doesn't make any sense
because the governor is primarily an
elected official these guys bought the
team and the failure for somebody like
Adam Silver to be like hey I heard that
argument but here's the truth they own
the franchise not the individuals if
people don't want to play in our league
they can go elsewhere and make a living
somewhere doing something else that's a
pretty good argument and I don't he's a
reasonable guy and he's afraid to say
the reasonable thing because then he
ends up a target is the irony though
that the destructive force that you're
talking about actually transcends race
because so I got you that Adam silver
he's yeah and I'm a white guy so I
better yes you know offers some penance
here but the simple truth is that most
likely one day even though he's doing a
pretty damn good job in terms yeah
anomic he'll be replaced and he'll be
replaced most likely I would guess if I
had to guess it's probably me by a black
woman yeah okay actually if you were
just putting odds out I think there's a
good chance so but let's just say it's a
black man or a black woman well yeah the
second that that black man or woman does
anything that those guys don't like
they'll say that they're an Uncle Tom
and a sell the rest of it so it's like
you actually have no protection in the
world of social justice no matter you
know to be in the second do you want to
use your minority status against you I
mean everyone watching this knows that
yeah like those guys leaving be treated
worse they'll be looking at Adam silver
going oh those were
good old and that's why you need to have
somebody who's willing to stand up and
just respond and I think the fear is in
getting engaged in that fight but
ultimately we need to be having more
battles ironically enough we need to
have more reasonable people who are
willing to step into the fray because I
do think there is a huge I don't think
I'm almost a 1 billion percent certain
there's a cuz they respond to my show
and I'm one of the only people who's
making these arguments there's a huge
silent majority out there that thinks
that these arguments are ludicrous and I
think it you know kind of translates
into the Democratic presidential debates
I think everybody is so afraid of being
attacked my thing is being attacks a
good thing right like well it means it
means that you are having an influence
and that they're afraid of the influence
that you're having so you know III don't
run away from attack I kind of enjoy you
know like what it was the old argument
you know like a pig in the mud likes
enjoys being there I kind of like being
down in the muck rolling around getting
in a fight good fight every now and then
and I clean though when it happens to
you yeah and you're just trying to do
something decent yeah that's the thing
for me that I had to adjust because I
actually don't mind the hate now yeah I
agree it's like right well they're all
talking about me PS waking up in the yes
going really you're doing that but but
there's a there's still a part of me
that's like well I'm trying to be so
frickin decent that I understand that
yeah I tried I talk about all that stuff
and it's like that still is what they're
going for which really tell it says more
about them than it says about you
totally and I think the other thing I
would say for everybody out there is
these stories last 24 hours so initially
you know early on in Twitter I
understand that feeling where suddenly a
hundred people decide you're the most
awful human being on the planet because
of something you said that really is
pretty innocuous right didn't know who
you were it out yeah and now you're like
an awful human being and and you know
used to I look at it I'd be bothered by
it now you know like I just say okay
like I've got three kids at home like
let's go down to the park you know like
you know 24 hours there's gonna be
something new that they decide to get
offended by and it's not going to change
the way that I talk about my opinions
and ultimately I also don't think it's
going to have an impact on my career now
maybe I'm wrong maybe at some point I am
going to totally get cancelled but in
the
Kancil culture that we live in because
somebody decides I said something that
they don't like but I think working yeah
yeah yeah yeah
I think that we've entered the world
where the art once you get and that
that's where I think you and I both are
now my audience is not suddenly gonna
say I hate clay Travis and completely
abandoned me right and so I think the
the fear out there is that there's not
people who are gonna have your back I
feel like we've reached the point where
we have a lot of people who have our
back and it's just basically a perpetual
war yeah there's so much there yeah we
could do five hours yeah yeah it's just
attacking all it's important because I
do I sense it especially at colleges
with the young kids that are just afraid
to get in the fight oh yeah bit more oh
I see that all day it's like you're
seating a lot of ground yeah well that
will gladly tile it to you you know yeah
and that's to me the scariest thing
about our culture today is and I wrote
about this the other day and I certainly
wrote in my book there's a difference
between I disagree with you and here's
why and I disagree with you and you
shouldn't be allowed to make the
argument that you're making right the
cancel culture to me is really scary in
our country because there are a lot of
people out there who want to cease the
debate in general and just cancel you
out of the debate and that's
fundamentally anti-democratic it's anti
first amendment it's anti American
values and the few the the fact that
there's not more people standing up to
fight against that and in favor of that
like again I think back to Howard Stern
for instance who's now evidently gone
whoa to right in many of the ways that
he started to go a little bit woke but I
think I think it's because he fears all
the things that he's done in the past
that if he continues in this era they'll
go back and they'll track through all
these different tapes and everything
that he said over the years but I think
that you know what they found was in his
early days people wanted to silence him
right and what's wild about that is it's
a big circle because it used to be
conservative people who were like in
that position and now I think
conservatives have realized wait a
minute we need to have a robust
battlefield of ideas and in the fact
that you know in that in my life
liberals could be the people on a campus
saying I'm upset because of an idea
or I'm upset like they are in San
Francisco right now because of this old
mural of George Washington it's on the
wall in that school or I'm upset because
of this statue that's out there or I'm
upset because of a word that somebody
used or phrase or a sentence or a
paragraph that somebody wrote it's like
how sensitive have we become as a
society it honestly is that I think the
most scary thing that's going on in the
country today yeah you know there's that
great moment in private parts in the
Howard Stevi where the the executive
comes out and he says you know the
people that love you watch yeah listen
to you for seven minutes a day he's like
the people that hate you listen to you
for an hour and a half yeah and it's
like yeah they listened they hadn't but
they listen now that culture is on
social media dominating the hate culture
and I remember talking with the
politician a while back when I was
working in politics and we were talking
about yes/no votes and you know a lot of
times you and no matter who you are what
political persuasion you have you'll
stand in front of that yes no question
and you'll be like it's a really complex
you know I don't even know what this
means right now the lawyer and I'm
standing there like I don't know whether
I should be yes no they're like he's
like 30% of people vote no no matter
what right like it doesn't matter what
the question can be because you always
look at those yes/no ballots and it's
never something never wins like 95 to 5
right it's always 70% roughly yes 70 to
30 is a wipeout right in a voting booth
and there is a certain segment of the
population that is titillated by being
offended by things right like that's
their thing the problem is we have
allowed those people to be voices that
we give way too much legitimacy to
because one is a minority of voices and
two it's not actually reflective of life
there's that Pew study recently that
came out that said people hate political
correctness right whether you're white
black brown Asian whatever you are you
hate it and and yet we've allowed that
culture to predominate
yeah we're seeding it basically yes
percent a hysterical 8% yeah so then it
leads to the question which is what
everyone asks me and I don't know what
the answer isn't and I've thought about
it a lot and I can only come up with
some things that I wouldn't even want to
say but how horrible does this thing
have to get before it implodes like what
what do you think would actually
we caused it to lose its energy so I
think that first of all there are a lot
of people I think who have been funny
and smart about ridiculing you know for
instance the Chicago Cubs we had the ok
sign right and the Cubs are like oh my
god this fan is banned from life the ohh
Epstein is like I was literally
shivering when I was seeing it and I
don't about you but the vast majority of
people like when I was growing up if you
look down when somebody did that you got
punched in the arm right I think that is
a vast majority of the perspective here
I mean purpose yeah yeah right yeah yeah
yeah so the argument that is out there
that common things which are used by
white supremacist groups somehow render
them unusable is a so utterly absurd
argument right because I'm like well you
know white supremacists drive cars right
white supremacists fly on airplanes
white supremacists shake hands right
like the idea that you're gonna identify
a symbol with a particular group and try
to ban it to me
proves the hysteria that we're currently
living in like we saw with Nike saying
oh Colin Kaepernick's offended by the
Betsy freakin Ross flag right and so
we're not going to allow that shoe to be
released and so I think reasonable
people look at this and start to
recognize the hysteria so I had a you
know somebody sent me this but I think
it's a funny question what if white
supremacists just went all in on 90-year
like flip the script right and they're
like like every event that we do we're
only going to wear Nike does Nike cancel
itself does it change the name of Nike
right imagine how funny that would be if
like this next the next KKK rally you
know like if everybody at the KKK yes
right and everybody's like a million
people stand around the year but what if
the KKK I should like had a sense of
humor and irony which they probably
don't right because they're ideologues
who are absolutist which are always the
people who are craziest right but what
if they showed up in all Nike gear and
they're like Nike is now white
supremacists endorsed company we only
wear Nike head-to-toe right would Nike
be like we're gonna ban like the the way
that you follow the logic down it's
absurd path
and you I think that they're almost like
you got to smuggle a little logic into
their ridiculous write them and and and
that's like that's like my argument
Martin Luther King was opposed like said
that like in in he gave an interview
where I think it was in Ebony magazine
back in the day and he was asked a
question about gay rights basically like
how do you I'm afraid my I'm gay like
what should I do he's like well it's
probably a medical condition you should
go talk to a doctor and like if a
political candidate gave that answer
today they would be cancelled right like
particularly if they're Democrat god
forbid so I was like if you immediately
respond I went to Martin Luther King
high school like do we have to take
Martin Luther King's name off my high
school do we have to tear down the
Martin Luther King memorial I think when
you start to put people like well no I
mean like that was in the 1950s I'm like
yeah well George Washington was around
in the 1790s right like Thomas Jefferson
was around in the in the seventh in the
in the 18th century like what do you
want to do there like in terms of
analyzing it so I think you need to flip
it on people and make them realize oh
wait the people that we believe our
icons of our universe are actually
flawed human beings as well and maybe we
shouldn't judge every single act they
did predicated on whatever the rules are
now but yeah that one I love like if
white supremacists are just like we're
head to toe Nike now instead of burning
it yeah right if you're like it and then
what is Nike do like he's like oh what
do we change the name of the company the
way you like like how do we how do we
take our brand like this idea that
because somebody you disagree with likes
something you have to not be touched by
it
[Music]